kaboul est ainsi en train et large
sourire pour entamer cette journée rien
ne laissait présager le coup fatal
qu'andréa horvat espérait porter à son
adversaire libéral en soulevant une
histoire de possible corruption une
attaque portée dans la circonscription
de kathleen wynne
de surcroît le travail se poursuit dans
l'autocar de campagne andré horvath et
son équipe passe en revue les événements
à venir
on arrête prévue dans les prochains
jours à peterborough le deuxième dans
cette circonscription baromètre rend la
chaire néo-démocrate fil des événements
suivants bain de foule devant l'hôtel de
ville de toronto pour marquer le début
du mois de la fierté gay dans la ville
reine placé mais j'ai l'impression
andré horvath et la seule chef de parti
provincial à y participer
de tous les dignitaires présents c'est
elle qui reçoit la plus grande ovation
[Applaudissements]
ensuite direction sainte catherine pour
une promesse d'investissements
supplémentaires en santé mentale
élargissement de l'assurance médicaments
et de la couverture dentaire
investissements dans les hôpitaux pour
réduire les listes d'attentes la santé
est au coeur du programme néo démocrates
c'est la grande priorité des ontariennes
partout en province teater immobilier
lundi pipi visite ensuite les bénévoles
et partisans du npd dans niagara centre
et c'est là qu'elle reçoit cette
confession de militants
puis pour la première fois en 11 ans
andréa horvat fait du porte à porte pour
rencontrer les électeurs
une activité qui lui a manqué comme
celle ci
[Musique]
la médiatisation du mari de nos soins
les ontariens iront aux urnes dans trois
jours et tout indique qu andrea horvath
et le npd obtiendront leur meilleur
résultat en prêts de crainte ici
philippe leblanc radio canada toronto